ruff more than a decade cake fall was
one of David Cameron's closest advisors
considered to be one of the most
influential women in British politics
she witnessed firsthand some of the
biggest events of our time of clothing
of course two general elections three
referendums fairness fallish she's now
became known as a gatekeeper the name of
her new book about her time in Downing
Street and she's with me now welcome to
you it's written in the present tense so
is it a diary what is this what you
wrote at the time or just a
reconstruction no it was a
reconstruction but I I wrote it in the
present tense because I wanted it to
feel immediate and and and to get the
reader to feel the sort of the events at
the time and what was your job
effectively with daily care so my job I
was partly CEO of number 10 along with
Ed Llewellyn and and we work closely
with the officials and a close advisor
to the Prime Minister but another one of
my roles was the the gatekeepers they
call which is a which is an important
job about how the Prime Minister
prioritizes their time the people who
were in the room when the key decisions
are made and to a certain extent the
sort of atmosphere of the house you know
is there a bunker mentality is the gate
always shut is it allowed to be open and
this is a it's a very it's a personal
thing really it since yeah I mean people
would you know be watch game with
friends of course like being the hand of
well I think Michael Gove thought he was
hand of the king whichever character was
yes it is very personal and and and all
number Ten's are personal to the person
in charge there the atmosphere of a
number-10 tends to come from the premier
from the Prime Minister we got and the
problem you know what you go into in the
book is in a sense a tour you know you
know what power prove right again it all
ended in failure referendum well look I
think politics in the end you leave you
leave number 10 and therefore there's a
moment when you feel it there is a
failure look I believe that the
referendum was coming to British
politics and it was I believe in the
democratic process of asking the
question to the public we you know I
regret that we didn't win the argument
but that booth
national trauma which is thrown up it
could be argued that a more skilled
leader would have found a website
stepping in a bit like Tony Blair well I
I don't think that's a scale I think
that's not leadership I think leadership
leaders it is because in the end are you
never going to allow the public to
answer a question about one of the most
important relationships we have I think
pushing important issues under the
carpet and hoping they go away adds to
grievance and I don't think that shows
political leadership so I think dodging
that issue is isn't a good thing the
country's better if I think have that
referendum
I think the referendum was coming I
personally campaigned on the other side
but our side lost and I think there is a
sense of closure and I think everyone
Britain at least most people at me
personally feels you know the boats
moved on and let's all get together and
make the best of it and you saleable I
mean you make it clear that you think
you lost because of Boris Johnson no I
didn't say that's in the book I didn't
say that at all I do I've just read the
bit about you know who's going to
support you Michael Gove you can live
with Boris Johnson what no felt was one
of you and you felt betrayed
well no Boris Johnson is a very talented
politician and having Michael Gove
intellect and Boris's charisma on the
other side of a campaign was formidable
and turned out you know they were so you
know part of the reason why we felt was
they they had very good people putting
forward very strong arguments but we you
didn't feel on the basis of what Boris
Johnson was saying to you what he was
saying to David Cameron you didn't feel
that he was really sincere and being a
leader I felt that he was sway I thought
he hadn't decided which way and I
thought one of the important reasons why
he was swayed to the other side was he
was thinking about you know his journey
to number 10 and and that was his motive
really for going for it I mean look
Boris has always been Pro reform in
Europe he's written extensively ever
since he was a sort of young adult about
how Europe should change at that moment
I believe that a human flu intial
argument for him going to leave was also
weighing up the opportunities and
yeah I mean this book does confirm you
know the criticisms from the outside
that that Cameron government really was
a kind of chum okra see that you know
you all knew each other socially you had
similar backgrounds in the case of the
boys long and been to Eton and all the
rest of the I mean it was a pretty close
privileged circle that's true I think
what I say in the book list it all all
prime ministers have inner circles
around them you know after we left
resume had an incircle Boris Johnson we
read about everyday about Dom Cummings
and part of that is that inner circle
creates a momentum difference is that
quite often Prime Minister's construct
that in a circle from people that they
didn't necessarily know that well before
but in your case you were all made we
won't mates we met through politics in
fact the people who were at number 10
with David Cameron it was a wide group
of people a meet Gail lists are Gabby
Berta more people who came to the team
later Craig Oliver but there were a few
of us who knew each other not through
school and university but through
working at conservative research
department that great institution of the
Conservative Party it was a political
inner circle not Amit's political circle
and what happens now to the legacy of
Tamara means pretty shocking really
isn't it well no I know I think David
Cameron was an excellent prime minister
he restored our finances at a time when
the nation was really in a bad way he
was a reformist he believed in equality
he stood by the world's poor yes for now
you remember David Cameron for the
referendum and the divisions over the
last few years I think the referendum
was the right right call and I hope he
stayin umber ten after you lose an
argument about how you want your nation
to go is a bit like staying in Humber
ten after losing you general election
and I think we all know from politics
that that wasn't an achievable aim even
if you wanted to he would have been
forced out in the matter weeks okay for
thank you very much indeed her book is
called the gatekeeper life at the heart
another time nice thank you